You are the explorer
Give me a hard copy
fred
your dream to be
enforced [I]
Wish to find the lost
What we seek?
far [greater] than you ever
imagined
Your soul will never be quiet until you find this place
It is your sting
There's a major exploration afoot terrible disease murder of savages the Journey may well mean your life
Don't go, you'll not know you when you return I know this is a sacrifice for all of us. They will be worth a
man's Reach should exceed his craft [I]
am proposing in Amazonia
Contain a hidden
civilization
If we may find a city where one was considered impossible to exist
[it's] many well write a whole new chapter in human
Are you insisting that these savages there are equal their civilization?
may well three days [off] I
Call it Death the ultimate piece of the human puzzle
Strongly advise you to abort the mission become far too dangerous
Must come back the rest of tiny
I
Stay here and struck them to provide for the children while you wondered the jungle
He does care ashes
You don't [even] care [about] them
Don't care a shallow
Let's search for said I can no longer bear the cost you've come to doubt its existence now
not only does it said provide all the answers you seek from